american and russian authorities say
they are discussing a potential prisoner
swap that could free two americans
currently detained in russia they are
wnba star brittany griner who is
currently appealing her nine-year prison
sentence and marine veteran paul whalen
who has served just over two years of
his 16-year sentence back in april
another marine veteran trevor reed was
freed in another prisoner swap after
spending nearly three years in russian
detention he had been sentenced to nine
years overall and he is now sharing his
experience in an effort to push for
greiner and wayland's freedom as well
trevor reed good morning thank you for
being here we appreciate it
i want to talk about griner and i want
to talk about paul whalen but first i'd
love an update on your condition it's
been a little more than four months now
uh after your
985 day stay in russia behind bars you
lost a lot of weight in that time simple
question how are you now
i'm doing great so i've regained all of
that weight that i lost uh
and physically i'm feeling feeling
really good
eating healthy working out
feel feel good psychologically as well
glad to hear it and we're talking to you
in texas uh your home state from the
fort worth area uh you know the rest of
us really would struggle to understand
what britney griner and paul whalen may
be going through right now in russia
you're one of the few people on the
planet who have insight into it
what are their conditions likely to be
terrible so it depends
you know kind of at what stage of
imprisonment you're out there the
detention facility where
brittany griner is being held
is is probably going to be
significantly better than the forced
labor camp where paul is currently being
held so
conditions at forced labor camps there
are
you know significantly worse than than
in
the pre-trial detention facilities that
that you go to first
trevor you appealed your um conviction
in a russian court that's what britney
greiner's doing as well
what can you tell us about the process
and what she's up against
uh so appeals basically as far as your
imprisonment goes you'll stay
at the
usually at the same pre-trial detention
facility that you were in
before you were convicted
while you're there you're going to be
meeting with your lawyers there's a lot
of waiting um
you may be requesting expertises or
or trying to
to find new evidence
in order to appeal the
the ruling of the previous court during
that time and that appeal
could take you know
years
basically but
in the end all of those appeals are you
know fake they're as fake as the first
trial that you receive all all courts in
russia are fake
i mean do you have any idea how she's
being treated how you were treated how
they would treat her i think that's what
people are concerned and worried about
yeah i'm not sure
her situation is a little different than
mine was as far as other prisoners
[Music]
how they may treat her
but obviously the relationship between
you and any any prison officials or
or police there is is not good so they
they don't like americans trevor
you know she's a professional athlete uh
you know when you think about the
overall health she had going in to play
that season of basketball there uh your
health declined significantly while
you're in prison i mean what are the
conditions like from a just a physical
safety and health point of view
yeah the those cells they're uh
you know extremely dirty food there is
is uh
you know really bad so a lot of times
the the food there is rotten
you may receive like a broth that has
some fish bones in it um oh man they
give you like a
you know
vegetable juice or tea that's
unsweetened uh
if they give you that you're forced to
drink tap water
um
trevor you know we have to if we have to
get going but real quick psychological
what is your bit of advice
to them
uh just hang in there just know that
people are fighting for you and uh
just know that you
you have a lot of people supporting you
back here at home and that you know the
highest levels of the us government are
are attempting to get you out so so keep
the faith
yeah
and former prisoners like yourself
working on their behalf no doubt about
it trevor reed thank you so much we
appreciate you
thank you